So a couple of interesting Reddit threads
from the David Pakman show subreddit that
I spotted this morning. Of course, the David
Pakman show subreddit, the biggest David Pakman
show, audience discussion forum on the internet@davidpakman.com
slash Reddit currently 15,600 plus of our
viewers regularly participating in discussions
and commentary there. Um, I saw a post about
a conversation that one of our viewers had
with a Trump supporting friend who says, the
amount of mental gymnastics these people do
is unreal.
This guy is a Navy veteran and our viewer,
uh, said to his Navy veteran friend, how do
you feel about your boy Trump pleading guilty
to stealing money meant for veterans to fund
his campaign? And our viewers, Navy veteran
friends said, Oh my, it's all one pocket.
They steal my social security money all the
time. So I'm used to it. LOL. Yeah. That,
that is, um, an example of, uh, it's moving
the goalposts and it is sort of both sides
ism in a, in a different form, which is, Oh,
listen, Trump acutely, uh, defrauding people
through a charity that sort of like the government
take social security money or this or that.
Or I'm paying into a system that I might,
uh, not get money back out of, which of course
does not actually appear to be true. They
are mental gymnastics. But this is a great
example of how can you argue with that, right?
How can you argue with someone who will always
find a reason to say no? It's actually not
what you think. And it's not Trump's fault
in my support of him is not inconsistent or
hypocritical in some way. I say don't bother.
And we saw earlier this week the video of
CNN interviewing six uneducated white women,
so to speak, as as they are effectively in
terms of the demographic group. And you saw
that, uh, you know, it doesn't matter what
facts you present. Some of them will talk
around it if that's what they want to do.
And that's why we just need to focus on, get
out the vote. We need to focus on just getting
people who already agree with us to go out
and cast a ballot because you're not going
to convince people like that. Or at least
if you do, the amount of time it'll require,
will not lead to an effective, uh, a strategy
for winning an election.
Also from the David Pakman show, the subreddit,
this is really interesting. I saw the title
and the title is I'm becoming radicalized
by the right and then the viewer goes on to
say, now the title isn't what you think at
first. The rights actions and own radicalization
has made me a liberal, more radicalized in
my opinion of them. As they become more radicalized,
I have doubled down almost like a radicalization
death spiral. Another way to put it, I've
seen them more be more of a threat and a menace
than fellow countrymen. It's to the point
where I see them as inferior, closer to evil
and primal than civilized humans. Everything
they stand for, I see as a threat. And I'm
not sure what the answer is. In what to do
about it. This is very interesting because
we often talk about radicalization that takes
place, which makes, uh, w w which can take
somebody who is for example, on the left and
pull them to the extreme.
Right. And I've heard from your viewers who
tell me, David, I used to be moderate or on
the left and the internet echo chambers and
algorithms radicalized me to the right. This
is something different, but it's arguably
also problematic, which is someone on the
left sees the right becoming more and more
extreme and it makes them double down on their
own beliefs such that they start to see the
other side as something less than human as
this viewer is saying it's ugly. But I don't
think this is as rare as maybe we might think.
A really interesting perspective and I encourage
you to participate in the discussion on our
subreddit. I'm there on a regular basis. Producer
Pat is there, producer max is there. Uh, I'm
not sure Noah's spending too much time on
the subreddit, but Hey, that's okay. He's
got a busy, uh, he's got other tasks that
he's working on.
A David pakman.com/reddit. R E D. D. it.